ein journalist übrigens nicht fertig der
gefängniswärter löschen oder ihrem
vokabular dem tierpfleger landschaft der
tierarzt gibt es nur lose stehende der
seitenlinie entsteht als anlass war dass
der für die beschäftigten schluss macht
mit dem großen flüssen was soll's das
sony wohl die ganzen 40 jahre lang immer
wieder vertragen
die haben sich auch reals mich machen
und sie hat ein spezieller sogar seine
quasi gemacht haben
[Musik]
unüberhörbar
dieser mann trägt sein herz auf der
zunge christian harder
seit 38 jahren ist der mitarbeiter der
justizvollzugsanstalt lenzburg
ich begleite ihn während seiner letzten
monate im berufsalltag bis zur
pensionierung
[Musik]
kennengelernt habe ich christian habe
vor einem jahr bei dreharbeiten über
sicherheitsmaßnahmen im strafvollzug ein
sturer hardliner
ein sheriff aus dem aargau hat dachte
ich weit gefehlt
hinter der harten schale versteckt sich
ein sehr weicher kern
manchmal widersprüchlich aber immer
herzlich so erlebte ich christian harder
lenzburg zwei gefängnisse eine anstalt
die strafanstalt und das 300 meter
entfernte zentralgefängnis beiden sorgt
christian harder für die sicherheit im
moment ärgern ihn die laserscanner
welche die mauer überwachen
[Musik]
das heißt die laserscanner reagierten
und lösten einen alarm aus zu viele
fehlalarme im kontrollraum so hart sind
der tod für die sicherheit
also hat er den überwachungs streifen
ein wenig nach unten verschoben
nun testet er die neue einstellung sehr
pragmatisch so wie ich ihn immer lieben
dies ist einer seiner letzten jobs ende
woche geht dann nämlich in rente
es funktioniert ausbrecher und
einbrecher haben heute bei ihnen
praktisch keine chance mehr
das war früher anders wenn wir präventiv
gegen teppich und nach immer mehr regens
haben wir verständnis konnte und
zusätzlich für alles entwendet mit dem
auto gefahren ist haben wir noch linie
account haben einfach gewisse ist es
möglich ist der 5 sterne vom lenzburg
mehr als 150 jährige die mauern waren
nur vier meter hoch und die gitterstäbe
an den fenstern noch weich als christian
aber 1981 hier als einfacher vorzugs
beamte angestellt wurde
im vergleich zu heute seien sie damals
ein verschworenes team gewesen
daneben haben sich aber die arbeit und
der vollzug eindeutig zum positiven
verändert sonst wäre er gar nicht so
lange her blieben betonte mir gegenüber
mehrfach eintritte austritt aber auch
fluchten wurden noch fein säuberlich von
hand protokolliert bis der technikfreak
harder den ersten computer brachte 1989
überredete er den damaligen direktor zu
den ersten überwachungskameras und dies
gegen den ausdrücklichen willen von
einigen älteren kollegen über sieben
meter hoch ist heute die mauer
zudem wird sie mehrfach elektronisch
überwacht die strafanstalt verfügt unter
anderem über ein programm zum erkennen
von handys und ein abwehrsystem für
drohnen er braucht es mir gar nichts zu
sagen dass er alles mit initiiert hat 24
stunden wird jeder schrank und jede türe
in dieser leitzentrale überwacht denn
hier laufen alle systeme zusammen
ich staune über seine fachkenntnisse
großteil vor dem sich selbst eröffnen
krieg setzt dann funktioniert die
gefahrenen davon profitieren wir daraus
müssen lehren die hat eine können aber
im jahr fragte sie vor dem ziel
gleich daneben auch im untergrund in
einer ehemaligen
celle hütet habe einen weiteren schatz
[Musik]
risiko gestand aber mit sachen sucht
hilfe braucht wollte sind davor dieses
agali die auto gibt romer kann ich mir
gut sagt der großmeister der stirn
geschrieben und gestapelt auf einer
resolution auf die rente sieht der
schufa ab großstädten und auf 300 liter
super im schnitt und 120 stücke und da
hätte der menschen geben zu der
klassischen stück vom stollen metallteil
jeder schlosserei in irgendeiner branche
bis man die hand alles zieht der
vertraute peripherie oder mit stoff
selig köpfe ganz schön ist schon einig
wurden in die flucht gelungen ist mit
der strickleiter mit einem metall
geschlossene wo sich der mensch schafft
hand und hat stück für stück irgendwann
mal abzüglich aller kosten wo man noch
keine metalldetektoren kann also fragte
volumen sind da nicht immer leicht an
doch sie einige wochen und ist erst mal
über die automobile welt zum nur
gewaltausbruch und daher leicht
und da habe ich immer zwei kamine der
brust oder veränderte aber wenn es eine
ganz raffiniert machte jobs ebenfalls im
museum wurfsterne messer schlagringe
alles gegenstände welche bei gefangenen
entdeckt und konfisziert wurden
darunter sogar eine selbstgebaute
schusswaffen und eine einfache
schnapsbrennerei das irgendwie
verschwunden
da brauchte man kenne mich ein großer
schock
also das mag ich natürlich unheimlich
kompliziert gewährte der ökonomisch und
dass ich für mein bester ja der hammer
so sagen es ist einfach weniger schlimm
aktiv verrät nicht aggressiv in den
augen
das fühlt sich schlaff ist weniger
schlimmen aber schön ist natürlich
letztlich sprachen sich für potter innen
und wenn wir uns bekämpfen
historisch neu ist gut denn sie gut
tatsächlich angriffe von danach stellte
stattgefunden hätte woche also
gesundheitlich etwa 30 jahre mindestens
zurück in die gegenwart kader
präsentiert sein allerletztes baby die
neue videoüberwachung 120 kameras
dokumentieren das innen und außen leben
der strafanstalt bis zu einer woche
können die aufnahmen gespeichert werden
aber betreut die sicherheitssysteme
nicht nur er bildet auch die mitarbeiter
darin aus
mit dem 30 fachen zoom lassen sich sogar
kleine kieselsteine ausspähen physische
kontrollgänge werden so fast überflüssig
wenn eine sicherheits den staatssport
aufgrund von deren technik kommunizieren
aber drückt mir vor der ganzen technik
verdiente sich wieder fangen bitte mit
bis zu der halter bewachung der
hauptvorteil endlich frauen viel
lockerer umgang mit dem tagesablauf
die gefangenen können sich heute
innerhalb der sache als relativ frei
bewegen
sei es bei der arbeit oder in der
freizeit dennoch insgesamt 15 stunden
täglich müssen sie sich in den zellen
aufhalten
ein weiterer vorteil für die insassen
dank der fast lückenlosen überwachung
lassen sich übergriffe schneller
erkennen und beurteilen
das hat eine präventive wirkung
[Musik]
christian horner ist sichtlich stolz auf
all diese technischen errungenschaften
zu haben aber das ist jetzt so gut
entwickelt hier die nachricht
hier hat die rhone moment das jetzt nur
1 alles sie vermehren und jetzt konnten
neue generation wohl schon mit dem hof
boxen ist
und wenn ihm alles zu viel wird dann hat
er noch sein boot seit 15 jahren findet
er mit seiner lebenspartnerin erholung
auf dem wasser aktuell schippert er über
den neuenburgersee hier erlebe ich ihn
zum ersten mal so richtig nachdenklich
fast schon melancholisch bewegend werden
verloren wurden einfach würde die
technik profitiert das was studiert das
volk service annimmt oder bezirks wie es
irre geführt wurden also nicht dass man
als 20 jahre lang möglich nun erstmalig
jetzt muss ich wieder ruft passen sind
hätte schutz nehmen so politisch solche
aussagen sind auf eine richtung lässt er
sich nicht festlegen
er habe auch das betonte er immer wieder
kein mitleid mit den gefangenen
sein auftrag sei aber diese
menschenwürdig zu betreuen
dass ihm dies gelingt habe ich mehrfach
erlebt wenn ihr also meter lagen wo was
in der zelle bis zum modul entstehen
aufgrund von dem autor
gesundheitszustand und gilt weiterhin
als extrem gefährlich
gleichzeitig befürchtet er dass in
zukunft der stadt aus angst vor der
justiz die gefangenen noch mehr schütze
als den einfachen bürger nun allzu lange
muss ihnen das ja nicht mehr kümmern
denn seine zukunft ist außerhalb des
gefängnisses
[Musik]
noch aber dominiert der strafvollzug an
seinem ersten arbeitstag drückte man ihm
einfach eine pistole in die hand
tempi passati city führen zwei musiker
das waffen und das training polizei
deutschem ohne zwischenfall passiert mit
schusswaffen ist ja in japan kate
entsetzen ausgelöst und denner thani
mich die person donnerstagnacht mit der
damalige leitung ausgerufen
aber wir brauchen sie instrument um im
absoluten notfall verteidigen
[Musik]
dieses instrument ist der taser in
lenzburg kam er erst einmal zum einsatz
umso wichtiger ist die regelmäßige
ausbildung dem gerät
[Musik]
diese elektro impuls waffe macht eine
betroffene person für einen moment
immobilie hanni und das display ganz
wird jetzt wegen manipulations
gartenschule funktionieren habt ihr euch
nicht passieren aber kürzer und es ist
das ereignis als viele positive ist so
umstritten
die außenseite trauernde muss müsste was
macht oder um mit dem pfarrer deshalb
auch halter muss sie so einen
selbstversuch über sich ergehen lassen
[Musik]
pixie wie vor einfach froh aber physisch
physisch psychisch überhaupt nicht merkt
gar nicht
die zwei fehler haben sie denn das
problem xii
der größte schmerz vertrieb der
mittellinie
von teese und der sicherheitstechnik
zurück in die zeit hat seine
strafanstalt noch wirklich der strafe
und nicht der resozialisierung diente
christian aber zeigt uns die einzige
noch vorhandene ursprüngliche zelle
[Musik]
druck erhöht da keine mehr wochen aber
die türen unser flügelspiel gesellschaft
sie sich 1000 fachleute ich halte die
erhöhte vollzogen später das spiegelbild
der flachbildschirm die logische schon
gar nicht glauben
ein solcher kriege da ist er wieder der
verständnisvolle vollzugs mitarbeiter er
glaubt an die positive entwicklung der
meisten insassen deshalb würde er ja
auch die lebenslange verwahrung
abschaffen da die machen also erst
völlig bitte gesellschaft probiert jetzt
korrigieren
das der absolute sicherheit gibt
umstritten ist dass man immer schon die
male davor aus wer ist schuld wenn er
durch berlin wählt der psychischen
drucks hätte man kann es probieren einem
rückwärtig oder nicht schuld wer ist
schon dass der andere mit den
klimatischen deutschen von merkel kommt
der teil mit den schwaben ist schon ende
der durchsage
aber ist ein vehementer verfechter einer
rechten resozialisierung dazu gehört für
ihn das training vom körper und geist
[Musik]
nicht so schnell vergisst
in diesem fitnessraum steckt kein
einziger steuerfranken das ist die ganz
wichtig und er ist geschmälert
einmal pro woche dürfen die insassen in
den kraftraum
christian rader unterstützt sie bei
ihrem training ich spüre sein engagement
für diesen sport aber auch für die
insassen
im trainingslager haben nichts gemacht
was sind mosaik die macher leistet
blickte sozial gehen schmachten stück
grün
die haben wir den formen haben auch ein
stück halle wo doch mit tiefen
einschnitten blick funktioniert entfernt
noch heute kritisieren außenstehende und
besucher das tolle studio
das sei ein übertriebener luxus die
täter würden verwöhnt stadt bestraft
jeder kennt diese argumente zur genüge
ich mache sich damit die kamera 1 255
damit das ziel von photonischen abrufen
vor 30 jahren erhielt er von einem
professionellen bodybuilder einem
trainings- und ernährungsplan ende des
jahre lang so lang beobachtet zwischen
zwischen 30 und 40 schweizer meisterin
tanja aber das tor zog hier die flammen
die nach plan und die trainings und seit
funktionieren auf anhieb wurde er
schweizer meister bei den über
40-jährigen
[Musik]
wir fahren jetzt die jungs dran
wohl deshalb wird er auch nach der
pensionierung noch einen abend pro woche
in seinem studio verbringen
dann aber ist es endgültig so weit
harders letzter arbeitstag in seinem 5
stern
[Musik]
ein letztes mal durch den iris scanner
dann folgt die ehrenrunde
ich bin froh dass ich meine ja thomas
blug
die ausstellungsmacher
[Musik]
ja
presse.com schäfer vor dem offiziellen
abschiedsessen gibt es noch einen apéro
mit der geschäftsleitung exklusiv der
ort heute ein weinkeller früher eine
arrestzelle und zum ersten male liebe
ich ihn so richtig diplomatisch erlebnis
würde beruhigt immer wieder motivation
es ist einfach nur super was mir hatte
vermachen sieht um zwei uhr nachts
gewisse beste danken durchaus gute onkel
mit halter verschwindet ein original aus
dem strafvollzug meint sein schiff das
gefühl es berufsumfeld kennengelernt hat
das verbauen sondern es ganz oben
denn ist das durchaus positiv firma also
ist wenn die persönlichen mitarbeiter
christian 40 jahren bekannt wo sich so
entwickelt innovative sachen die manöver
sollen aus direkten austausch stolz
entlassung für die meisten insassen der
erste schritt in die freiheit
ob dies bei christian aber auch der fall
ist ich bin mir nicht sicher
wer seinen job so leidenschaftlich
erfüllte für den ist die pensionierung
eine echte herausforderung
[Musik]